[Music]
hello welcome to a very special episode
of worth it one stop we got the worth of
crew in the car here if you put our
names above our heads you know we are
revisiting a place that we've been to
before it's called APL in Hollywood it
was family-style meat and one of the
signature features of this restaurant
was a special knife that Adam Perry Lang
the chef made himself and because we ate
a very tender meat last time we're going
to be going back to eat a proper steak
and see him make this knife which has
the very impressive price of nine
hundred and fifty one dollars but it's
for a good reason nine nine hundred
fifty dollars and one cent so we're
gonna see if that get made weren't a
steak it's a great day to be also Andy
came the most prepared for this shoot as
you can see from her yes
hi I'm Casey lund I'm a blade Smith
specializing in swords and chefs knives
I'm Adam Perry Lang APO restaurant of a
chef and blade Smith and I'll say it
master master swordsmith and blade Smith
he won't say it but he's the man the
swords and chef's knives yeah those two
don't seem to be the closest in the
family together but I guess they are
they are they cut things yeah
swords are for bigger things your
fascination for blades where did that
come from
probably eighties b-movies really you
know always wanted a sword as you know
typical boy against as a teenager and
that's when I started and today we're
gonna be making the Balinese steak knife
why is it called the felling a knife to
commit a felony in California it has to
be an amount about 950 it's priced to be
a deterrent you know it's not priced to
sell I'm just looking to hold on to my
stuff I invest so much time and the
entire customer experience that for me
it was a logical last piece of the
puzzle I could procure the beef aged it
cook it gets put out to the customer I
don't want to give them a crappy blade
you know I wanted to give something that
was truly meaningful so for me it was
really a statement we've heard chef
describe for the making of food hundreds
of times but never of a knife so if we
could just go into now the step-by-step
process of making this night
you know we'll take a round borrow steal
break that down into bar stock under the
big forging hammer the ABL steel that we
used was developed in Sweden and it was
designed specifically to be used as
razor blades crush that down into a flat
plate essentially blades get cut from
that bar the shape really came out of
the function of it how much of the blade
you actually use when you're cutting a
steak is typically like only the first
third of the blade so for me the actual
design came from what's called a drop
point hunters where the the blade itself
is shifted down on the most basic level
it's just mouthfeel cutting with
something as opposed to like tearing it
up and having this like feathery cottony
piece of like torn meat cutting with a
good blade it's just like it already
starts off the whole moment right
without the proper heat treat doesn't
matter what steel you used if you didn't
heat treated right it's garbage that's
that's where my specialties been at for
so many years developing these digitally
controlled salt pots it's actually how
we met and when you started talking
about possibly blowing myself up I said
you know I think I'm gonna come friends
uh-huh you know what are the risks a
high-temperature salt is running 1,600
degrees Fahrenheit if you had a little
bit of moisture one drop of water it'll
blow like a shotgun out the tube so
you'll blow 1,500 degree molten salt out
so by heating up the blade and if you
cool it quickly enough you'll form a
microstructure toka martensite it looks
like a bunch of needles all stacked
together for this particular steel then
after that once you can touch it with
your hands and has to go into liquid
nitrogen and that brings it down to
negative three
degrees Fahrenheit and that will
actually complete the hardening process
when you sharpen the edge and you look
at it under an electron microscope you
can actually see the carbides they look
like a little saw heat the smaller those
are the better and slicer the blades
gonna be I mean you can really kind of
stake with the store-bought knife
there's no question about it but the
question is the intention behind the
blade you know it's like a transfer of
energy of just like hey we did the best
that we could in just this whole entire
process and it's it's interesting to
know the story behind rather than just
kind of creating these meaningless
objects that just are there for us just
to use is at the end of the day what's
the point I must ask we're gonna eat a
steak tomorrow
what steak what do you recommend that we
actually pair this knife with I'm just
such a huge fan of the tomahawk because
you know you get all these different
textures and muscles that you would get
here you have like four different ones
you have the meat along the bone you
have the deckle outside you have the I
made you have all the things in between
so I'm good is to say the tomahawk steak
which is the revival I'm getting hungry
[Music]
so here we have the APL 950 dollar and
one cent felony knife at the forge we
saw the high polished finish and this is
a tumbled finish as it is at the
restaurant which I really love
how's the hand feel feels good menacing
just getting so much pleasure from
holding a knife okay alright so the
knife is not the only weapon at the
table we also have the tomahawk
I thought you everybody these guns
although also yes
cheers mm-hmm
the only thing left to decide is who
gets to go first you got the first step
Rock Paper Scissors shoot damn it
Oh oh my goodness Wow okay so this is my
cut
yes man not that I want to hand a really
dangerous knife to a baby the strength
of a baby could have cut through the
head but don't give knifes babies oh how
do you feel I keep looking at the knife
it's a weird I like just picked up this
beautiful piece of steak but my eyes
stayed right here uh-huh and I cut into
it it felt like I was putting on his
love that immediately
mmm-hmm that was so good oh really I
warned finishing taking a bite of
something so delicious but when I'm done
my bite yes it's knife time oh I would
not be afraid to take the path less
taken with this knife I'm gonna cut the
meat off the bone right here my favorite
part of the meat Oh
I'm super jealous that you got to do
this
[Music]
Gina up here there's a different part of
the meat the deckle oh oh oh that's just
it's a different texture at the top of
the tongue they get a slightly different
knife experience
I think my teeth are jealous of this
night
oh yeah the idea of a family knife it's
it's fun it's goofy what it really does
is it allows us to appreciate the level
of detail that goes into this night you
sit down and see this knife here and you
just think oh this is gonna be good it's
always the little details they're like
oh this is not just gonna be some old
dinner like when you look at my fashion
choices and you're like this is gonna be
a good time
no no one thinks that okay fine but they
do when they look at Adam
[Music]
oh yes
[Music]